der größte teilchenbeschleuniger der
welt der large hadron collider für die
westentasche
nur wenige zentimeter groß doch die
leistungen übertreffen die klassische
anlagen um das tausendfache ein
deutsches forschungsteam hat jetzt das
unmögliche möglich gemacht die rede ist
von einem mini hybrid beschleuniger der
laser & electronics kombiniert können
diese kleinen und günstigen mini
beschleuniger bald die aufgaben der
klassischen teilchenbeschleuniger
ablösen die teils mehrere kilometer lang
sind das könnte tatsächlich die
grundlagenforschung revolutionieren
allerdings nicht die der physik die
antworten auf all diese spannenden
fragen gibt es jetzt bei pixum sciences
user hier gibt es drei mal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
diese neue erfindungen lässt
teilchenbeschleuniger schrumpfen die
rede ist von einem neuartigen hybrid
beschleunigung der teilchen auf
lichtgeschwindigkeit bringen kann und
das achtung nicht auf einer strecke von
rund 27 kilometer sondern innerhalb von
nur wenigen zentimetern entwickelt wurde
diese technologie von einem
internationalen forschungsteam und auch
fachleute aus deutschland waren dabei
der erste teil ist ein laser getriebener
plasma beschleuniger und im zweiten teil
sorgt der vor beschleunigte
elektronenstrahl dafür dass weitere
plasma elektronen auf tempo kommen heißt
also der miniatur plasma beschleuniger
ist nicht nur enorm leistungsfähig die
technologie der hybriden plasma
beschleunigung ist zudem auch deutlich
kostengünstiger als der betrieb der
herkömmlichen anlagen wie genau
funktioniert der neue mini hybrid
beschleuniger und haben durch diese
erfindung die großen klassischen
teilchenbeschleuniger endgültig
ausgedient die antworten auf diese
spannenden fragen gibt es in diesem
video
keine frage die klassischen
teilchenbeschleuniger wie beispielsweise
der large hadron collider am cern
benötigen enorme mengen an energie um
die teilchen zu beschleunigen das
geschieht in kilometer langen
beschleunigerring und mit der hilfe von
elektromagnetischen feldern der
teilchenbeschleuniger large hadron
collider lhc bei genf gilt als eine der
größten forschungsanlagen der welt
der ringförmige tunnel 100 meter unter
der erde ist 26,7 kilometer lang
doch außer acht lassen darf man dabei
eine sache nicht bei solchen
experimenten geht es um die großen
forschungsfragen überhaupt
beispielsweise beschäftigen sich die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
mit protonen kollisionen wodurch sie die
erste nano sekunde nach dem urknall
simulieren die forschungsteams erhoffen
sich durch den ausbau der anlage bislang
unbekannte elementarteilchen auf die
schliche zu kommen
seltene phänomene zu untersuchen und
genauere messungen durchzuführen
grundlagenforschung also die enorm
wichtig ist doch viele anlagen dienen
mittlerweile auch ganz praktischen
zwecken vor allem in der medizin und
industrie werden diese geräte genutzt
beispielsweise um keine oder tumorzellen
abzutöten oder um eigenschaften von
materialien zu verändern
die spektakulärsten wissenschaftlichen
entdeckungen der neuzeit wurden
überhaupt erst durch den einsatz von
teilchenbeschleunigern möglich so konnte
man beispielsweise überhaupt erst
ermitteln wie materie aufgebaut ist und
dennoch solche teilchen beschleuniger
wie der lfc sind vor allem eins groß und
kostenintensiv zudem kommen diese
anlagen trotz ihrer gigantischen größe
an ihre grenzen pro meter strecke
schaffen sie nicht mehr als 100 mega
elektronenvolt denn dann gibt das
material nach und hier beißt sich die
katze in den schwanz denn um mehr
leistung bringen zu können müssen sie
noch länger gebaut werden aber auf
anderem gebiet da gibt es riesige
fortschritte mehr energie zu erzeugen
und das in immer kleinerem maßstab die
neuen teilchenbeschleuniger
die sind in der lage auf einem weg von
nur wenigen zentimetern rasend schnell
teilchen zu beschleunigen sie nutzen
anders als die herkömmlichen
teilchenbeschleuniger keine magnete
sondern extrem energiereiche laserpulse
diese werden in einen sehr schmalen
kanal beschossen in dem sich plasma
befindet durch die pulse lösen sich
elektronen aus dem plasma so entsteht
ein sog artiges elektrisches feld
welches die teilchen hinter sich
herzieht und dabei beschleunigt das
ganze wird in der fachsprache als das
prinzip der kiel wellen beschleunigung
bezeichnet denn der strahlt gehen das
gasförmige plasma geschossen wird
erzeugt einen elektro
und das erinnert an die quelle eines
bootes denn es reißt die elektronen aus
dem plasma mit sich und beschleunigt sie
dann die elektronen surfen dabei quasi
auf einer welle im plasma mit dabei
werden sie innerhalb weniger millimeter
bis auf fast lichtgeschwindigkeit
beschleunigt der riesige pluspunkt dabei
ist keine kilometer langen strecken
notwendig ganz im gegenteil den laser
plasma beschleunigern reicht eine
rohrlänge von wenigen zentimetern solche
miniatur beschleuniger finden so auf
einem ganz normalen tischplatten bisher
gab es einen entscheidenden nachteil die
diese plasma beschleuniger mit sich
brachten die gesamtleistung der miniatur
anlagen ist begrenzt in der
vergangenheit kamen leser beschleuniger
auf mehrere gigaelektronenvolt vor zwei
jahren gelang einen weltrekord bei der
platz habe schon einige fachleute hatten
damals mit einem 20 zentimeter langen
beschleuniger erstmals energien von 8gb
elektronen volt erreicht dafür notwendig
einen 35 femtosekunden lang laserpuls
von 850 terawatt leistung wurde in das
wasserstoffgas markt geschickt dass ich
bei diesem experiment in einer glasröhre
von nur rund 20 cm länge befand das war
ein echter meilenstein für leser plasma
beschleuniger sollte ich effektiver aber
sind immer noch die plasma beschleuniger
bei denen vor beschleunigten elektronen
oder protonenstrahlen die quelle
erzeugen das problem dafür sind
weiterhin großanlagen notwendig um die
zeit überhaupt auf touren zu bringen
doch genau das konnte das internationale
forschungsteam jetzt umgehen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben ein hybrid plasma beschleuniger
entwickelt der beide varianten
kombiniert und so profitiert die neu
entwickelte miniatur anlage von beiden
varianten ein riesiger erfolg sagt einer
der beteiligten wissenschaftler andreas
topp diese kombination galt vor wenigen
jahren als illusorisch
mit dabei waren unter anderem fachleute
der ludwig-maximilian-universität
münchen vom max planck institut für
quantenoptik sowie forschende des
helmholtz zentrums dresden rossendorf
und des deutschen elektronen synchrotron
desy in hamburg in einem ersten teil
treffen starke laserpulse auf einen gas
strahl aus stickstoff und helium
so entsteht plasma zudem wird ein
elektronenstrahl erzeugt der von der
laserquelle mitgerissen
der erste teil des mini beschleunigungs
also die erste beschleunigung strecke
endet quasi mit einer dünnen metallfolie
diese blockiert aber nur den laserstrahl
und lässt den gebündelten schnellen
elektronen strahlt durch dann folgt der
zweite teil hier gibt es einen zweiten
gas strom aus helium und wasserstoff
dieser wurde im vorfeld bereits durch
leser zu einem plasma ionisiert genau
hier sorgt der elektronenstrahl dann für
eine weitere quelle
so werden neue elektronen aus dem plasma
gerissen und weiter beschleunigt so
kommt es also zum turbo es handelt sich
um eine spektakuläre premiere denn so
konnte erstmals ein kompakter teilchen
basierter plasma beschleuniger
realisiert werden die plasma
beschleunigung mit laser wird in der
fachsprache als laser wakefield
axxelerate kurz bezeichnet diese wird
bei dem neuen mini hybrid beschleuniger
mit der beschleunigung die auf
teilchenstrahlen basiert kombiniert
letztere wird in der fachsprache als
plasma wake wood axxelerate kurz cabrio
fm bezeichnet konkret wird die pkw von
elektronenstrahlen aus dem laser
basierten beschleuniger lgf getrieben
beide beschleuniger sind extrem kompakt
und so hat der hybrid beschleuniger
lediglich die größe von wenigen
zentimetern die beschleunigungs spannung
dagegen ist mehr als 1000 mal höher als
in den konventionellen beschleunigern
wie die simulation der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zeigen der strahl getriebene
beschleuniger abschnitt bringt die
elektronen dabei auf 128 mega
elektronenvolt und das innerhalb von nur
einem millimeter
das entspricht einem beschleuniger
gradienten von mehr als 100
gigaelektronenvolt wie das
forschungsteam schreibt die fachleute
sind optimistisch dazu sagt einer der
beteiligten wissenschaftler stefan
karsch wir konnten bereits zeigen dass
sich unser kompakter klassen habe schon
mega ähnlich verhält wie seine deutlich
größeren konventionell betriebenen
bonbons daher sind wir zuversichtlich
dass wir mit dem aufbau in der nahen
zukunft extrem helle elektronenstrahlen
erzeugen können und so hat das
internationale forschungsteam schon
einige anwendungsmöglichkeiten im kopf
den teilchen können so auf kleinem raum
und zu geringen kosten auf touren
gebracht werde demnach könnte die neu
entwickelte technologie als basis für
die sogenannten freien
elektronen laser dienen damit gemeint
sind extrem hochwertige
strahlungsquellen die in der
wissenschaft dafür genutzt werden
biomoleküle und geologische proben ganz
genau zu analysieren superwichtig und
praktisch also für verschiedene
forschungsbereiche doch der zugang dazu
ist bislang begrenzt hier könnte der
neue miniatur hybrid beschleuniger also
abhilfe schaffen aber auch
forschungsgruppen gewiss dank einen
teilchenbeschleuniger zur verfügung
haben könnten diese neue technik nun für
ihre zwecke nutzen und weiterentwickeln
doch an den large hadron collider im
cern kommt er trotzdem noch nicht heran
der bietet dann nicht leistungen von
millionen oder milliarden elektronenvolt
sondern im billionen volt bereich also
das x-fache der leistung trotzdem
absolut beeindrucken was die forschung
auf diesen kleinen raum dort geschaffen
haben das ist schon absolut
beeindruckend wie auch dieses thema
neues zeichen entdeckt bisher
unbekannter materiezustand da geht es um
ein neu entdecktes tetra quarks hoch
spannende entdeckung also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
diesen kanal klicks umsatz im future
einfach auf den knopf einfach auf den
knopf 4 unter dem video klicken ist
absolut kostenlos und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran